بعلم الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه وسام
القاسم اهلا بك اسامه بدايه كيف هي
الاجواء لديك في الحرم المكي خاصه في ظل
انتشار هذه البرامج التوعيه والتثقيفيه
للزوار المعتمرين
اهلا وسهلا محمد تحيه طيبه لكم ولجميع
المشاهدين العربيه نعمل لكم الصوت والصوره
اليوم من ساحات المسجد الحرام وبالتحديد
ما بين باب الملك فهد وباب الملك عبد
العزيز انقل لكم الان الصوت والصوره كما
تشاهدون ازدحام شديد جدا امام باب الملك
فهد وامام باب الملك عبد العزيز احدى
الابواب المؤديه الى صحن المطاب بالاضافه
الى باب الفتح و باب العمره وباب الزبير
وباب السلام ايضا هذه سته ابواب التي تؤدي
الى الوصول الى صحن المطاف وادوار المطاف
الثلاثه العلويه طبعا بحديثنا اليوم عن
الشؤون الفكريه والمعرفيه في المسجد
الحرام نعم اطلقت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
برنامجا بشاشات تفاعليه عند بعض البوابات
التي تفيد وتعطي معلومات فكريه ودينيه
وثقافيه للزوار والمعتمرين بعده لغات وفي
مصدر ايضا خاص وخبر حصري ايضا العربيه
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ستطلق في الايام
القادمه روبوتات مجهزه لترجمه للترجمه
لعده لغات امام بعض ابواب
الى المطاف طبعا محمد حينما نتحدث اليوم
عن هذه الجهود الكبيره راح اتحدث عن جهود
كبيره جدا لعده وكالات في رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين هذه الخدمه وعدد من الخدمات ايضا
المقدمه
للزوار والمعتمرين اليوم في المسجد الحرام
منها الترجمه منها ايضا الرد على الفتاوى
منها ايضا الدلاله على الابواب التي يرد
الوصول اليها الزائره والمعتمر وايضا
ارشاد التائهين هذه مراكز متواجده على
جنبات ساحات المسجد الحرام نتحدث ايضا
اليوم عن الجهود الصحيه والاجتماعيه
والانسانيه الموزعه على بوابات وساحات
المسجد الحرام لتقديم هذه الخدمات للزوار
والمعتمرين لكي يعيشوا هذه التجربه بشكل
افضل نتحدث ايضا عن التجربه الثقافيه
الموجوده هنا في توسعه الملك عبد الله
توسعه السعوديه الثالثه وتحديدا هو معرض
كسوه الكعبه وبعد بعض المعارض الموجوده في
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه هذه الخدمات
واكثر التي تقدمها الحرمين بشراكه ايضا مع
عدد من الجهات طب بحديثنا اليوم عن هذه
الخدمات نتحدث ايضا عن الاعداد المليونيه
اليوم التي وصلت الى المسجد الحرام منذ
بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك واستمرار الخطه
التشغيليه الثانيه التي تنتهي مع نهايه
العشره الثانيه ثم الابتداء الخطه
التشغيليه الثالثه التي تنتهي مع نهايه
شهر رمضان المبارك كل هذه الخطط التشغيليه
خطط ممنهجه لتيسير وصول الزوار والمعتمرين
الى الاماكن التي يريدونها سواء من خلال
توزيعهم عبر ابواب المؤديه الى المطاف او
حتى الساحات المتوزعه على جنبات المسجد
الحرام طبعا اليوم الحرم ممتلئ بالكامل
هناك في الساحات الشرقيه والساحات الغربيه
عدد من اللوحات التي تعطي بيانا واحدا ان
البحاره ممتلئه ان عليكم الاتجاه الى
المسار الاخر هنا ياتي الرجال امن الحج
والعمره وعدد ايضا من المنظمين والمتطوعين
لايصال الزوار المعتمين الى البوابات التي
يريدون ويودون الوصول اليها لبث هذا
التزاحم ايضا تفتيت هذا التزاحم
والسير الخطه التنظيميه بشكل محكم وجيد
جدا طبعا اليوم ايضا محمد نحن امام ايام
ستشهد ايضا زياره الكثير من الزوار
والمعتمرين وصولهم ايضا وتوقعات بان تزيد
هذه الاعداد خلال الايام القادمه اذا هذه
الصوره من امام المسجد الحرام مع الزميل
اسامه القاسم اسامه شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات